it was a success Philippine government
officials said when President Ferdinand
Marcos Jr returned home from a state
visit in Beijing earlier this month with
billions of dollars in investment
pledges and more than a dozen agreements
Marcos and president Xi Jinping also
agreed to restart discussions on a
possible joint oil Venture in the South
China Sea the friendship between but on
Tuesday the Supreme Court delivered a
surprise verdict it declared an oil
exploration agreement with China and
Vietnam dating back nearly two decades
unconstitutional medium ownership Teddy
casino is one of the former congressmen
who filed the case in 2008. the
Constitution was very clear it's it's
basically very categorical
that exploitation of natural resources
are reserved for Filipinos and Filipino
corporations Beijing views almost the
entire South China Sea a 3 million
square kilometer area as its territory
the 2005 agreement covers less than five
percent of that but includes Waters
Manila considers its own
claim reinforced by an international
ruling in 2016. oil exploration in the
South China Sea has been on and off the
government's agenda for years while the
2005 agreement languished in court the
two countries signed another deal in
2018 only for it to be terminated four
years later
so the big question now is it if Marcus
can succeed but whether it's such an
undertaking with China is possible at
all
and they say the ball is in China's
Court whenever the Philippines talks to
China it always ends up with Beijing
telling Manila what is ours is ours what
is yours we share it's difficult to come
up with a workable agreement if the
premise of the discussion is in that
framing but president Marcos believes
searching for oil in the south of China
Sea is crucial I think there might be I
think there might be ways around it that
will not entail a
government-to-government partnership we
have to find a way it may not be a
necessity for China but it is for us
with reserves of the country's only
offshore gas plant shrinking and an
economy that relies on oil imports
the importance of the South China Sea to
the Philippines future energy sources is
something on which everyone can agree
partner below Al Jazeera Manila